لدى منافسين الاستراتيجيين هدف تاريخي هو
اضعاف روسيا وتفتيتها لكننا سنحقق اهدافنا
رغم الاعمال العدائيه ضدنا من اغلب دول
النيوترو
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم
خلال
الاجتماعات الحديثه
اسرائيل ترفض تسليم جثمان الاسير ناصر ابو
حميد الى عائلته بعد استشهاده جراءه تدهور
حالته الصحيه سلطات الاحتلال قالت ان
القرار جاء لضروره تتعلق بمفاوضات صفقات
تبادل الاسرى والمفقودين الاسرائيليين
وصفه تمديد فلسطينيه بالاجراء الاسرائيلي
ودعوات لتحرك دولي
السلطات الافغانيه تعلن منع الفتيات
والنساء من الدراسه في الجامعات في عموم
البلاد وذلك بعد اقل من ثلاثه اشهر من
اجراء الالاف منهن امتحانات القبول الامم
المتحده عبرت عن قلاقها من القرار
والولايات المتحده ندد به في حين عبرت قطر
عن خيبه املها ودعت الحكومه الى مراجعته
بعد ان اطلق ايلون ماسك استفتاء بشان
تنحيه عن منصبه وجاءت النتيجه بتاييد
الاغلبيه لقرار التنحي مالك تويتر يتعهد
بالالتزام بنتائج الاستفتاء عندما يجد
شخصا احمق بما فيه الكفايه ليحل محله
مشيرا الى انه سيتولى اداره الفرق
البرمجيات والخواتم بعد استيقالته
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]